a very real and sudden lurch towards the
prospect of a no-deal
brexit the british prime minister told
the uk
to get ready the deal on the table is
really not
at the moment right for the for the uk
and
now is the time for the public
and for businesses uh to get ready for
january
the first because believe me there's
going to be change
either way there'll be change whether
it's a canada style deal or
an australian style deal the comments
follow high-level talks between boris
johnson
and the president of the european
commission in brussels on wednesday
after a three-hour working dinner
compromises
remained off the table negotiations
however have resumed
with sunday set as the new deadline for
reaching a breakthrough
the uk officially left the eu on january
the 31st
it's been in the transition period ever
since subject to eu rules and
regulations
while it tries to reach a trade deal
without one the uk falls back on very
basic
world trade organization terms often
called an australia-style
deal but what it really means is the
sudden unplugging of britain's economy
from the world's largest trading bloc
and the prospect of checks and tariffs
on goods going between the uk
and eu on sunday the new deadline
will be exactly a year since boris
johnson returned to downing street
having won a landslide in the election
largely on the promise of being able to
deliver
brexit 12 months on and the repeated
promise of a trade deal with the eu
though is still to be honored and now
hopes of a deal are drifting away
seemingly irreconcilable differences
on fishing quotas business competition
rules
and how the new arrangements will be
enforced have dog negotiations for
months
and in a possible sign of things to come
images of tailbacks of trucks on the
road to the port of dover and the
channel tunnel in foxton on thursday
logistics companies are reporting a
surge in orders
ahead of the brexit deadline a warning
too
from france that british citizens may
need visas to stay in the eu longer than
three months
the eu suggested it's ready to keep the
continent's roads open to british trucks
and let the uk operate flights for a
period of six months
providing the uk does the same but the
british governments promised a hard
break from the eu
come what may on december the 31st
without a willingness to compromise it's
difficult to see what avenues are left
eve parker al jazeera london
jonathan list is with us now political
commentator and deputy director of
the group british influence he's on
skype from london
just as a sort of big question first
jonathan should it have been this
difficult
i made the point at the start of this
segment four years
since the vote and it's all come down to
the last few days
i think it was always going to be
difficult because britain
wanted something that was undeliverable
that is to
have all the benefits of eu membership
without any of the responsibilities
and now it's trying to secure
unprecedented access
to the eu's market without being tied to
any kind of eu regulatory framework
trying to secure
a perfect vision of sovereignty which
doesn't exist anywhere in the world
apart from north korea
while while trying to negotiate a trade
deal which by definition involves some
kind of pooling
of sovereignty and agreeing to a shared
set of rules
so then what are the alternatives as
boris johnson now starts talking about
the possibility of a a no deal brexit
um and then he says things like all the
canada model or the australia model what
do these things actually mean
well their euphemisms to reprogram
the kind of language that people
understand um
they're not honest shall we say the
canada-style brexit sounds great because
we know the calendar is a beacon of free
trade
but even that would represent a hard
brexit uh
with a huge loss of gdp an australia
style outcome is even more ridiculous
because that means no deal at all now
it's not true for start because
australia has some deals with the eu
on side deals side deals with trade it's
also
negotiating a deal with the eu so it
doesn't like having a so-called
australia
style deal and it's also a trade between
australia and the eu
accounts for 11 percent of australia's
exports
and it's also very far away the trade
the gravity model of trade
whereas for the uk 43 percent of our
goods exports go to the eu so obviously
the eu is much closer it's much more
important um than
australia is to the eu and eu is to
australia
is britain and i think neve mentioned
this in his report looking at
possible chaos come january 1st you know
we keep hearing about this idea of long
queues at the dover port
and and the like what's your view on the
on the likelihood of that happening
it's a certainty because for the last of
47 years we've been
inside the eu's economic instruments and
now we're being wrenched out to them and
that's even with a deal
we're still going to leave a single
marketing customs union and that is
going to require
new checks taking place immediately for
tariffs and standards and that's going
to lead to huge tailbacks
and that's going to be massive
disruption to the economy now the the
bank of england
has estimated that the damage from a no
deal brexit
is going to be worse than the damage
from covet and you know the lse has
estimated
an 80 uh reduction in gdp compared to
what we would have had
over the course of a few years so this
is this really serious stuff
which people have not been prepared for
and part of the reason they haven't been
prepared for it
is that boris johnson delivers these
bullish statements talking about
australia
and not telling people how their lives
are going to be affected
not great is it thank you jonathan for
your analysis on that jonathan lewis
joining us from london
thanks